hello I'm Jalen Jackson from the
Rochester Institute of Technology have a
joint appointment in the school of
interactive games and media and the
school of mathematical sciences my talk
today is called how to train your
robotic sea turtle or Close Encounters
of the M kine and it features unit
evening
and coming up with this title here I
decided to find a maximum number of
characters that would meet the
acceptance of for the abstract so that's
what I did and this vertical bar here as
everyone knows is a symbol for the the
boolean or' and in the original title it
was sandwich there were no spaces around
here but since then I've noticed that
it's gone through several changes that
have ended up being printed out as a
slash which I thought was odd since the
the Wolfram Alpha uses that in there as
well but they don't seem to call that
Wolfram slash alpha so today I'm just
going to go through a little background
and motivation first and then get into
discussion of what went into designing
the the various aspects of the
interactive music video that I'll show
you and play for you in a little while
so I used a combination of Mathematica
unity linked in the unity 3d game engine
to produce this interactive music video
that features this what I call apes
artificially intelligent multi-sensory
signal and pattern perceiver embodied is
a robotic sea turtle along with these
six playful dolphins nicknamed at pod
Calypso so I'll be talking about how to
design what I call 3d choreographic
switch is really just calculating paths
of motion that that the sea creatures
would take and then fashioning some
geometric objects to go into the aquatic
world and then constructing some
interactive musical instruments so I
should say that this this interactive
music video is really intended as a play
along that's performed by a group of
twelve six actors who are in the roles
of scientists and six dolphin what I
call although they're dolphin
impersonators I like to call them in
personify er since they actually are
making sounds and so forth on this whole
play-along has done staged on a mixed
reality platform that's built around the
sailboat so the sci-fi story line goes
like this and that's on the next page
but I did want to mention the background
for this comes from what I've been
working on over the last couple of years
as I was teaching a course that was
tailored to the first year science
majors we used the elementary
introduction to Wolfram language book
and they got very far along with that
and then towards the end of the semester
I wanted them to be able to do some
creative work with what they've been
learning and break up into groups and to
teams and so forth so this over the last
couple of years this ended up working
pretty well in that context but if
you're interested in learning more about
the background here the then you can
access this video from last year okay so
here's the storyline the a pod Calypso
has taken refuge within yes okay sure
that is that okay
still okay I can make it you think
that's about that okay yeah what I might
do actually is go to here and it's gonna
make it easier for me to slide through
here I think but I can make it even
bigger than is that okay okay yeah so
here's a very highly detailed map of the
Caribbean trapezoid so the story is then
scientists aboard riff raff that's this
as I was saying this mixed reality
platform and you usually have a screen
in front of this but an exploratory
vessel from the cetacean intelligence
and communication investigation lab
they're seeking to make contact and
carry out research but this a typical
tropical troop of marine mammals will
mate remains pretty elusive and
cautiously distant so although
observations from far away do reveal
that Apokolips a likes to perform
expressive and Polly
big body movements while emitting exotic
percussion sounds and synchrony so as a
consequence the squad from sisal now
plans to carry out numerous experiments
deploying a purposely trained imps
that's the robotic sea turtle to conduct
novel song and dance routines composed
from myriad mixed messages of music
motion in math and the conjecture here
is that such actions may draw a pod
Calypso nearer giving rise to close
encounters of the amp kind now if that
didn't all sound too strange I did think
it might be beneficial for us to take a
peek at what was an earlier version of
the the video and then I'll be showing
you how some of things that went into
making doubt but also showing the
enhancements that have come along so
let's just see what we got here see if
YouTube's gonna play as for us
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay so that was a pretty pretty plain
version now how do I so as you notice
the the the path that they were all
following I don't know whether many of
you recognize that but we'll see the the
mathematical form for that it has some
significance in that it's it's
essentially a combination of parabola
and ellipse which i think is interesting
since of course the ellipse is the
typical orbital pattern of planets
around a star and then the parabola is
the typical simplified of course shape
that a projectile will take under the
influence of gravity close to earth so
combining those two I think it has some
significance there the so this is this
is actually what I started off doing was
coming up with something I said well
okay expressive social activities that
combine music motion in math we get
square dancing line dancing hoop dancing
kung the lines drum circles so okay if I
figure this is not too far of a stretch
then those are all on flat surfaces
since we're out in an aquatic 3d
environment we wanted to have similar
movements that could be designed to be
performed upon a periodic task curved
surface so just you know Mathematica
Wolfram language makes it really easy to
experiment with various combinations of
curves and then in this case it's not so
important I guess that it'd be on a
surface because the surface isn't
visible but in this case I too have a
way of orienting
although they're all gonna they're all
gonna rock roll and everything else once
they once they get the music going the
basic path they need to have a sense of
orientation so I used the the gradient
to a surface in order to get the the up
Vector as it's called in in unity part
of the 3d frame of forward and right and
up so here's an example just playing
around with something like this and you
know I should emphasize that that all of
this sort of making is not intend to be
just a one-time deal what I hope that
students will do is they'll they'll get
a hold of this they'll take their own
songs to come up with their own designs
and then they'll they'll play out their
own scenarios and in particular I'm
hopeful that in addition to just having
it be a sea turtle robotic sea turtle
and dolphins they could adapt this to
potentially create like something like a
Mars rover that could be sent off to
some distant exoplanet and design
something that could interact with
hopefully friendly talented creatures
that they would encounter there so now
in order to actually take this and use
it to control what are called game
objects in unity we need to actually
write c-sharp code that's the scripting
language that is placed typically when
it in something called an update method
so it runs every frame so maybe one
sixtieth of a second it's it's running
at and so it's called a script component
that's added to a game object and unity
I've been trying to work out ways to be
able to have this automatically be
generated I haven't been completely I
haven't been successful at doing that
yet so in the meantime you still have to
you can use this to design it but you
still have to go in and actually do some
things in the Unity game engine itself
can't do everything just from from
Mathematica using unity link okay so the
next thing involved what I call
fashioning some geometric objects
I know you can tell but here's here's
apes the robotic sea turtle in some
various well you can see from the top
view the front view and the side view I
thought it was interesting as I started
to think about how many different moves
could be choreographed and so I was
thinking having having the ability to do
a yaw maybe with just a simple maybe 15
degrees left center or right and then
the same thing with pitch 15 degrees
forward middle neutral and back and then
with a roll 15 degrees left centered and
right so when you put those three
together you get 27 and isn't it
convenient that our alphabet goes up to
26 letters so if we throw in a blank it
means that effectively you could be
writing out text messages and
translating them into these various
types of news as I started to play
around with with this idea of and I call
this thing a jukebox I realized that
because of the structure of the shell on
on Ames's back
it could be divided up into three
different zones if you're familiar with
audio stereo plugs or something called a
chip a ring and a sleeve so this this
kind of conveniently goes along with
that so the way that this is organized
there are these three panels let's look
at the neutral position right here that
would be if you go one two three one so
it's right here in the middle so this
this pattern right here represents these
three Center hexagonal patterns white
gray and black that would be the neutral
position and then the that's the chip
then the next what I call the ring here
is a alternating white and black white
black white black white black and then
black white black white black white will
see that used later for specifying
musical notes as well but for the just
emotions and so forth here
that's the neutral pattern now notice
that in this case if we if we go up to
here these are all representing a yaw to
the left all nine of these and then you
know for example these represent the
rolls left these represent the rolls
right and so so there's an encoding in
this graphical display that Ames can
produce that can be corresponding one to
one with again the letters A through Z
and the and a blank now I got interested
in how how distinctively well how
capable would it be let's say for some
creature to be able to figure out those
eventually and I so I did this feature
space plot first of all
and notice how nicely the groupings all
came out here so it looks like Wolfram
language is is pretty good at picking
out the similarities and the differences
among those I'm not going to run this
right now I did this experiment earlier
and it I don't know how good the network
connection is and everything else but I
this through just to produce some some
machine learning kind of capability here
to be able to recognize these here and
you can see when i when i again i just
used i typically i would be creating a
lot of variations in in the way that
they're facing and even how dark and
light they are all that to make it a
little bit more of a challenge to make
out these these 27 distinct patterns but
I just took just as an experiment you
can see it actually figured out all of
them although there was some right here
that the seven and the ninth one got a
little bit mixed with with that one
there as well ok so instead of having
the actual you know alphabetic letters
which I think pod Calypso would probably
not really be able to figure out that
quickly the these other patterns then I
just put them together in this sort of a
structure here but we'll see that
once we get infected I think I'll go
ahead and launch this this unity
application now I was having just a
little difficulty your earlier in my
room I guess it's expected right before
you give a talk that you start to have
glitches so but I was I was I'm gonna go
ahead and just manually launch the unity
here rather than use that in the hopes
that it yeah okay so let's open this
project
and we'll see so I thought it was
interesting because of cuz of the the
fact that we use you know red green and
blue in various combinations I mean
those are those are sort of like
orthogonal or at least linearly
independent colors right and then with
all these different Yas pitches and
rolls essentially those are all
independent so I started thinking about
a yet another way of associating those
27 distinct States with with sounds for
additional redundancy and so it's it's
just something that's just struck me
earlier that that developing this idea
of having let's say three separate
channels of sounds for example as you'll
see with percussion we could have a low
sound on a drum and a high sound on a
drum and of course none at all you could
have a high well that's that's using
pitch mostly but you could also have
variations in you know loud soft and and
well too soft would be nothing at all
but anyway you'll see what I mean here I
came up I came up instead with just some
some rhythmic motifs that I'll play for
you now and let me make this a little
bit bigger at the beginning they're all
sort of hold together there but so here
are some of the basic moves that all the
other ones can be produced from so if I
just do a yaw left okay so you got get
to get used to that that number that
duration of time and within that time
the pattern should establish itself
now here's here's the and of course yaw
zero means you don't hear that
instrument at all here's where I'm
really using two different percussion
instruments so again I'll play this one
so that's eight beats and then going the
other way so I think everybody here
could easily distinguish between that
first sound and the second sound and
then no sound at all but then what
happens when when you start to combine
and with other things I think we're
still pretty capable of picking those
out let's let's do the the sounds
associated with the pitch now so a
forward pitch you turn that up just a
little bit more so this makes it this
one's a little bit more difficult again
I'll play the first pattern and the
second one so the only difference is the
second one stops before the first one
doesn't go as long as the first one no
and then the other for the roll and then
rolling to the right okay so what
happens when we start to put all these
together let's suppose that the letter A
for example what's the letter A going to
be so that one is a yah to the left and
a pitch forward and a roll to the left
as well so and then what about Z for
example so that's going to be a yaw to
the right and a pitch back and I sorry
oh yeah y'all to the right pitch back
and a roll to the right
[Music]
okay so now the idea here is that Apes
would get into the the path along with
with pod Calypso here probably Ames
would start going around and start
making the sounds and the curious
dolphins would would eventually start to
follow along and then what happens is
that the as Ames starts going through
its various rhythmic patterns is that
some of them the dolphin immediately
behind Ames which you probably can't see
too well but what we'd start to have a
little bit of seal I guess we'll see it
coming up right along here would start
to to get along grooving along with them
okay and then Ames would go to the next
station and be able to again have a
similar kind of so yeah so this this
dolphin is doing the the roll the the
pitch movements again I usually prefer
to say things like twitch a twist
rock-and-roll rather than you all pitch
and roll but okay so after after Ames
has gone around and sort of given a
little bit of instruction to all of them
and let me move this out of the way then
Ames can start to add a little bit more
flourishes to to the moves so let's just
see what we get here so in in these
flourishes apes does the initial gesture
does takes the initial orientation and
then follows it up with a kind of a fast
fast break going back the other way so
here's another
[Music]
okay so so in any case we can we could
go through all 27 of those movies but I
think you get the idea here okay so let
me get get on with the next part here so
in addition to having sort of the what I
consider sort of like dance dance
revelution for dolphins where it's
mainly rhythmic based and so forth
wanted to have the ability to have the
the dolphins engage in a sort of a
version of Guitar Hero so needed to come
up with some kind of a an instrument
that could be played by the crew could
also potentially be in interacted with
by the the dolphins and that Ames could
could be playing on on its shell as well
so started off with the the piano
keyboard which we're probably all pretty
familiar with here but the one thing
about the piano well several things
about the piano keyboard it's it's it's
it was set up so that you can really
recognize the patterns but also that
your fingers could detect them and it's
not it's almost but not completely
symmetric if we see white black white
black white if that were black then it
would be completely symmetric on this
side and the other side here so that's
sort of the reasoning behind if there's
any reasoning at all going on here the
reason behind being able to are setting
up Apes shell to have this zone of 12 as
I said that was the ring zone before so
looking at looking at how to sort of how
this this is logically the keyboard si
de G a B to make it simple this could
just be C sharp d sharp and E sharp this
could be G flat a flat and B flat that
way
you get a pretty easy unambiguous way of
specifying all of those now what I
decided to do was make it so that Apes
could be taught songs essentially by by
using the guitar hero controller to come
up with a system that maps to to these
notes here in a really easy way I now
this doesn't show the modified colors
here but it imagine that's where that is
red right so red green and blue here so
with those you could press like red or
these two together to get yellow this
one to get green these two to get cyan
not to get blue and then these two to
get magenta so in other words using just
two fingers on any of those three middle
buttons you can specify you see how
these zones are red yellow green cyan
blue magenta so you can first of all
select one of six areas by using those
and then just use this one as the white
and use this one that's the black and
that way you could with just two or in
those three fingers play any one of
those song any one of those pitches so
here's a little I'm getting close to
time here so I'm going to go ahead and
breeze through here but this is this is
a little composition I came up with that
I thought had enough logic in it that
smart Dolphins would be able to figure
out some things it actually has some
symbolic significance in that it's made
up of ten call and response phrases five
calls followed by five responses
intended to signify shaking hands
gesture between humans but also note
that that if you look at an x-ray of a
dolphins flippers they actually have
five flanges that their finger like
bones they're also there's a structure
in the song based on a cycle of fifths
pretty natural progression harmonious
and so forth this would actually be how
you could play the song using the guitar
hero controller here so you see that in
this case it's using all
white keys but you can see that the the
colors change here as you're going along
I also made up another structure that
could could actually be placed in the
center of the path around Apes nepali
calypso so that even if the dolphins
couldn't see what was going on in aims
shell back they would be able to to see
something going on here as well and this
can be one octave or many octaves here
this this so-called polar pan piano
helix
so using Wolfram language to construct
these started off with just the the
annulus function here and then without
going into all the there are a lot of
details that go into how to go from
there to actually create the structure
inside unity link but essentially it
involves making game objects out of
these adding audio source components and
an audio clip added to that then the
transform component to make them
displaced the proper amount and rotated
and then configuring the colour property
is black and white and so forth and
we'll get a glimpse of what it looks
like in the unity project but it's it's
very tedious to do by hand and unity
whereas doing it with with Wolfram
language and using the the unity link
does make it go pretty easily so I think
I'll go ahead and jump to the net the
last video here let's see what I want to
do
you know you can see by the name of this
one here I had some troubles hopefully
this one will work
ok looks like we're gonna get it so I
don't have the guitar hero controller
with me I just I just using the the keys
1 2 3 4 5 on my keyboard instead right
now but if I if I play well first of all
just press down the the red key you can
see it on amps and then when I play that
the what would be the the white key you
get that I'll play the next note here so
using yellow and then the next one here
would be now I have ya the way this is
here I actually shaded it so that it
would look more like a traditional
keyboard in some way that would be the
key F but also it's an e sharp so it's
sort of in between there let's see I
gotta play it on the other side now I
you'll notice because of the song it
actually makes it's better to have the G
start here and then go up ABC and so
forth the actual song goes G C B e a d g
does that a couple times and then it
does some variations on it as well here
in a minute so anyway to finish it off
the to get to play the G over here I've
got to get the cyan and then play the
white and then to play the next note
that would be the a and then finally the
bead to be the magenta and then home the
C okay so let me go ahead and play the
full song for you I haven't put these
two videos together I'm still got a lot
more work to do on this as I said I
really intend for this to ultimately be
something that students could have
access to and be able to play around
with make their own versions of it so
I'll just go ahead and no here's what
the sort of the finished song sounds
like do I have to do it for the cow but
if I just do a command-i on that one
yeah well let let me do it
no I have no idea why we'd do this all
of a sudden here oh sorry not sound what
is it and what was yeah there we go
okay just say yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so haven't figured out when what the
tour dates are gonna be for Apes and
apocalypse Oh yet but watch for them
soon so I'd like to just take a moment
here to acknowledge a few important
people Albert Einstein just because
because I think that the question he
asks is something that I feel we can
actually prove it is a friendly place at
least in this show time space but even
more the the proof as I say requires
cultivation of kindness as much as
knowledge Kurt Vonnegut is an
inspiration to me for many reasons I'd
like to thank several RIT students and
on ones are who who made the Maya
version of apes and Monique Beauchamp
who made the the dolphins the rigged
models there and also Ashwin and
Elizabeth Smith who spent a lot of time
just talking to me and you've been
hearing a lot about computational X and
I've decided that the field that I need
to go into is computational comedy which
as far as I know nobody else has
declared that to be their expertise but